all cars go through rigorous handling
tests before being rated safe to drive
but did you know that there is one test
that most cars fail and new cars will
keep failing as well stick around as i
answer that question in this video the
moose test
the test is known as the moose test
developed by technical a swedish
motoring magazine it is a test designed
to simulate the sudden appearance of an
animal on the road unfortunately many
new cars aren't up to the task the test
involves driving at high speeds and
quickly swerving around an obstacle
without braking it measures a car's
cornering ability and resistance to
falling over you basically weave through
a set of cones that replicate swerving
to avoid something on the road like a
moose or in most countries that would be
a pedestrian or a car driving out from a
blind junction you should approach the
cones at around 40 miles per hour and
make the turn in without stepping on the
brakes the test is performed on a dry
surface loaded with people and baggage
to simulate real-life scenarios however
the test is so aggressive that almost
all cars fail even at lower speeds most
cars can pass the test at a speed of
around 10 miles per hour but anything
beyond that you will start to see cars
skidding out of control or even rolling
over completely most cars fail this test
because they're not designed to handle
such sudden movements the test may look
benign on your laptop screens but i can
speak from personal experience that the
amount of steering lock needed to pass
this test properly is scary even for
experienced drivers so why do cars keep
failing the moose test i've done some
digging to find out exactly what's going
on reasons for failing the moose test
became world famous when the 1997
mercedes a-class failed the test in
dramatic style at just under 40 miles
per hour the a-class has a tool body and
a short wheelbase design which is great
for passenger space but it puts the
centre of gravity of the car high a
car's center of gravity matters a lot
because the higher the centre of gravity
the easier it is for the vehicle to roll
over when cornering hard so while
mercedes failed the test a much older
and widely mocked car from former east
germany the trabant managed it perfectly
initially mercedes denied the issue but
eventually admitted that the car had a
huge problem and recalled all of the
a-classes sold unfortunately the recall
was quite expensive costing mercedes an
insane 160 million dollars 25 years on
and cars are still failing the dreaded
moose test there are various reasons for
this but perhaps the most common cause
is simply that manufacturers don't
design their vehicles keeping this test
in mind as a result many car makers
don't even know about the test and even
if they did the cost of redesigning a
car just to pass the moose test would be
too high for most companies i mean think
about it to successfully pass this test
you need to be traveling at a speed of
over 40 miles an hour then you have to
wind the steering in one direction fully
and then quickly unwind it in the
opposite direction this type of
aggressive driving is bound to unsettle
any car no matter how safe the handling
is secondly car manufacturers are under
increasing pressure to meet ever more
stringent emission standards and as a
result they're often forced to use
lighter weight materials in their cars
so they don't have the weight or the
sturdiness to pin them to the ground
during such aggressive maneuvers and to
be honest you will rarely encounter this
type of scenario on the road and it just
isn't considered a prime measure of
safety for car manufacturers primarily
the test is used to find the final
tipping point of new cars rather than
optimizing their designs to pass it
manufacturers would undoubtedly brag
about it if their cars could complete
the test at record speeds but if not
they usually stay silent about it most
moose tests on modern cars are performed
by independent reviewers and automotive
journalists not by manufacturers so what
are some big names that have failed the
moose test spectacularly and are there
any cars that are particularly good at
this test and managed to pass it
successfully failure and successes
although most cars fail the moose test
some designs are inherently conducive to
this type of testing but before we go
into the successes let's look at some of
the failures first a recent prominent
example of failure is the toyota hilux
when it nearly rolled running this test
at the required 40 miles an hour of
course the hilux is an off-road focused
pickup truck so you may say that it
shouldn't be subject to the same sort of
test and you're right but most modern
general suvs also fail this test
spectacularly cars like the jeep grand
cherokee or the porsche mccann seem not
to do well in this test despite their
promise safety and handling
characteristics these suvs are
incredibly heavy and as most of them are
built for off-roading they generally
have a tall ride height which doesn't
help when cornering quickly in addition
their suspension is usually very soft to
aid traction in the mud so in a way if
you were to design a car that wasn't
good for the moose test these would be
your ideal choices a solution to this
could be adding a stiffer anti-roll bar
to the rear however this design change
would impact the off-road ability of the
suvs and trucks so i guess manufacturers
of modern suvs and trucks make a
compromise there but what about sports
cars they should do well on this test
with their superb track handling
characteristics and racing pedigree
right but you'd be surprised that even
sports cars like the bmw m competition
or the mercedes-amg a45 have all been
undone by this brutal test the problem
with these cars is that despite their
highly tuned handling a sudden load is
placed on the rear end during this test
so when the drivers turn in the vehicles
would rotate properly but the reel would
slide around think of a giant pendulum
with all the momentum concentrated at
one end generating a lot of torque in
the opposite direction and spinning it
around however the approach speed and
the sudden aggressive maneuver are
enough to turn them around even with
traction control the other reason these
sports cars fail this test is due to a
lack of braking if the driver was
allowed to brake and turn in as they
would on a typical race track they would
actually place more weight on the front
of the car and generate a lot of
front-end grip to minimize the
understeer and the eventual spin but
since you're supposed to perform this
test without breaking even most sports
cars have no chance to get around the
cone without spinning around however
some cars really excel in this test the
first is the tesla model x an suv
similar to the cars i mentioned earlier
but its heavy battery pack is placed in
just the right place on the floor it's
centered in the middle which means that
despite it being much heavier than some
of its combustion engine competitors it
can complete the test at up to 40 miles
an hour but the all-time great that has
held the record on the moose test for 22
years is not some supercar or even a
small electric hatchback with all its
weight in the middle instead it is the
mighty citroen zantia activa v6 a very
average family saloon from 1999 and it
achieved an incredible speed of 53 miles
per hour this is insane considering most
modern cars fail the test at around 10
miles per hour it could only achieve
this because the zantia has a
computer-controlled active suspension
system that offers roll-free formula one
style cornering like the famous williams
fw15c
this car used a hydraulic suspension
that could adapt to every corner on a
circuit where a standard suspension
would overload the outside wheels during
the aggressive maneuver and lift the
inside wheels the active suspension on
the zantia manages the load on each tyre
individually instantaneously adjusting
the ride height of the car with its
variable shock absorbers the zantia can
change from a soft to a firm suspension
in less than half a second leaning into
the corners and controlling the weight
transfer perfectly therefore pinning the
car to the ground during the aggressive
maneuvers of the test because of this no
other cars have managed to even come
close to zantia's insane performance in
the moose test so if you wish to check
if your family car can pass the moose
test make sure it has an active
suspension system installed if not don't
even try to attempt it as you will most
likely fail and damage your vehicle so
the next time you see a car commercial
bragging about how the vehicle was put
through rigorous safety testing remember
that it probably hasn't been put through
the dreaded moose test the test that
most cars fail and will continue to fail
in the near future thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video there's more
click a card on the screen and i'll see
you there